The Joe Rogan Experience that [__]
Tick Tock band like what is this actual
law that bill has nothing to do with
Tick Tock yeah yeah there's nothing to
do with it it's all about having power
to restrict access to like what's the
deal
like a [__] evil well first of all
they nailed it Adam Curry doesn't think
they are Adam Curry's perspective when I
talked to him and Adam Curry's brilliant
yeah he said he thinks that they're
eating Tech in America's lunch and
they're trying to block them out because
it's a chinese-owned company and because
they're saying that China's scooping up
all the data guess what he goes that's
exactly what these other companies are
doing yeah they're all scooping up your
data yeah the idea that your data is
going to China is a problem it's because
China is represents competition and they
developed an app that's the most
addictive app ever
he's the [__] original podcaster he's
the Pod father he's number one it's why
yeah he's a couple things he was like
ground level he's super like deep in on
the internet man like and so yeah it
seems the same seems it's just an app
that they're making money off ads but I
will say what's I've never seen before
because Christine my girlfriend is like
uh she's on a Non-Stop and I really like
that she stops herself now but the fact
that you're in a position where you have
to stop yourself and like she wait she
can't wait for me to go to the bathroom
whatever so she can just start seeing
more of them and I I'm genuinely afraid
to try but I almost like almost like the
same rate I want to try crack once like
see what all the hubbub's about I want
to go on and be like is it gonna I'm not
into watching bite-sized videos
but what it does is it finds what you're
into and one of the ways I know that is
my 12 year old and my 14 year old have
[__] completely different feeds they
talk about it like my 12 year old into
like weird facts and strange things all
kinds of stuff that the 14 year old son
into the 14 year olds into like dress-up
videos it's like they're all people are
in a different [__] and that's what
it'll find your thing it's like really
good at that but it's also like super
invasive but then the question is how
much do we know other than what we found
out from Twitter how much do we know
about like what these other companies
are doing we you just sign up for
someone's app and then like how about
when you're talking about something and
then you see a Google ad for it like
what happened there yeah
well you know what's fun but you can
turn that off you can turn that that's
actually a function if you go into like
Facebook on your phone you can all of
them you put turn microphone off it's an
option so it doesn't do that if you turn
the microphone off though the app
doesn't do almost anything
that's too far following shopping habits
or something it's like maybe that's way
too far what about like an Alexa helps
you solve a crime because it like was
recording or something I hate that you
didn't know if you know if like this
whole uh thing with Edward Snowden
didn't come down we would and that was a
long time ago if you really stop and
think about it we would have no [__]
idea that there was a government
full-scale surveillance
program that was on the American people
like on everybody yeah like they could
spy on anybody they don't have to have
warrants anymore they're just they can
do whatever they want they can get all
your emails all your voicemails like
that is wild [__] and we found out about
it because a guy told everybody and then
had to hide in Russia
damn it's crazy AI scrapped 30 billion
images from Facebook and other social
media sites and gave them to Cops
look at that 30 billion images from
Facebook and social media sites and gave
them to police so now they have your
name and your face so if you have a fake
ID if you you know you get pulled over
they know exactly who you are and they
can run that through some [__]
computer that has a database
social media everything you've ever done
that's so much deeper than DNA evidence
because they would say that you know if
someone didn't have their DNA in yeah
you couldn't find some it was their
first time my crime and they weren't now
you could be like did you buy a shovel
recently you're in the system if you
have a phone what is this Tick Tock law
because people are freaking out about it
and people are telling me that I have to
look into it confusion is calling it The
Tick Tock law for the restrict Act is
not listed in there right but it's you
know that's like uh don't say gay Bill
never really says don't say gay in any
of it yeah the misleading one yeah it's
very misleading but that's also kind of
how it's being sold to people as like
this is what's going to stop the bad
tick tock stuff right but it's like hey
Tick Tock is not mentioned in here so
maybe it won't do that at all
so what does it say so this is what
instead of like just going after tick
tock they're making this sweeping act
the restrict Act is is described as a
systematic framework for addressing
technology-based threats to the security
and safety of Americans that sounds
ominous it grants the Secretary of
Commerce the authority to review
transactions by certain foreign entities
who offer information and Communications
Technologies products and services in
order to identify investigate and
mitigate undo and unacceptable risks to
the National Security of the United
States or its citizens this is this
includes but not limited to impact the
country's critical infrastructure and
digital economy sabotage or subversion
of icts in the United States boy that
could be interpreted a lot of ways
interference and manipulation of federal
elections which could mean you're just
skeptical or you're gullible and you
bought into some conspiracy theories and
you're talking about them and instead of
just being able to just talk like a
nonsense person you you get jacked so
much yes like subverting the Press
undermining the Democratic process to
steer policy and Regulatory decisions in
favor of the Strategic objectives of a
foreign adversary to the detriment of
the National Security of the United
States like man this is all so open to
interpretation
like yeah think of those things impact
the country's critical infrastructure
and digital economy that's easy to do
you can impact it what how what if you
impacted it in a positive way like what
do you say an impact it the digital
economy like how do they what what have
you done do you promote a certain coin
and it blows up
using eBay
yeah I mean if you if someone like think
about like these Bitcoin guys like if if
uh Elon posts a Dogecoin uh image
immediately Dogecoin goes up right
doesn't that impact the digital economy
so what does that mean yeah I don't know
so what if what if he says the crypto is
[__] because he believes it well
doesn't that impact the digital economy
yeah they could arrest him and are they
talking about the digital economy that
exists now are they talking about a
centralized digital currency was is
which is what China does is that what
they're saying they want to do are they
saying that Elon Musk will be illegal
for him to
I don't know what they're saying the
problem is the way that's I mean
obviously I'm not a lawyer but the way
that's written scroll back down so I
could read that the way that's written
yeah impact to the country's critical
infrastructure and digital economy the
end digital economy is included in there
like what does that mean
I don't know I've never made money
digitally yeah but look at this so this
thing information
Communications Technologies products or
Services right
so this is this is icts sabotage or
subversion of icts in the United States
again so it's information Communications
Technologies products or Services all
right okay so in order to identify
investigate and mitigate undo an
unacceptable risk to the National
Security of the United States so if you
did something that so subversion so
imagine if you said I think these people
are full of [__] and I think you know
what they're trying to do is gain
control the United States and I think we
should resist that that would fall and
there's that and they're selling it as
Tick Tock is doing this Tick Tock is
subverting our elections
they're not even selling it that way
these these countries are the foreign
adversaries that may do bad stuff so
they're like it's a risk that they're
going to do something bad with this yeah
like they've listed using a VPN as a way
to subvert that which would be what a
gigantic fine maybe 20 years in prison
what to use a VPN here oh how do you
steal a match how do you still
criminalize vpns
yeah
potentially criminalizing the use of a
VPN service or side loading to access
Services blocked from doing business in
the United States under the ACT due to
the text stating that no person may
cause or Aid a bad counsel command
induce procure permit or approve of the
doing of any act that violates the
orders issued under the ACT what oh it's
so confusing bro they're trying to gain
more power this is creepy this is not
good and I just gotta hope that people
wise up and don't pass this does it seem
like this is something they're they're
passing I don't know that it's gotten
that far I know it's been proposed do
you think it's an order to it where it's
like first we Bill uh China as going
after Hong Kong and Taiwan now we see
them as the enemy now a business
associated with them we can get rid of
that now yeah I don't know man I mean
the problem is like Tick Tock zombifies
people so like if you take it away
they're gonna Revolt yeah they want I
don't think you have to take it away
um but I think that act has nothing to
do with Tick Tock if people have like
legitimate concerns that people are
abusing and overusing Tick Tock that's a
conversation people should have sure but
if this this is not that it's not
because of that this is because
everyone's using it it's about what
they're getting yeah all that stuff
seemed very vague to me obviously I'm an
idiot but all that stuff seems very
vague when they're reading out like what
they can get you for yeah and that last
thing about acts that are listed as
impermissible under the act or whatever
the [__] the the wording was like what
the [__] is like you're covering all the
bases it seems like it's so open to
interpretation now imagine if something
like that existed during the pandemic
yeah in the beginning of the pandemic
where people go you know I don't know if
these [__] masks work you know you
would immediately get that's against the
public health that's against that that's
right that's exactly now we know they
don't work so then it was uh we think
that you can still get sick even if you
get vacced immediately you would get
banned from things